the alpha dog's been debunked this is
fascinating oh let's get into this kick
this down I want to talk about this
Google this right now we'll get the
heart details that dog has been debunked
by the person who invented alpha dog he
followed around this pack of wolves and
he noticed that there was this one wolf
a male wolf that everyone deferred to
this is when he made up the theory right
yeah and so then he wrote this book and
I think the book is called alpha dog
the next year when he went back to study
the same wolf pack he figured it out
that it wasn't they're not just
unrelated individuals that that was the
dad
so it was a family structure and it's
not a social structure and oftentimes
it's a female
and then just no one read it no one read
it people were like Alpha Dog we alpha
dog took off like he was on TV shows
immediately yes people were like yes we
this alpha dog thing we're behind and
then he came out the next year one year
later and was like guys it's wrong it's
wrong Alpha dog's not a thing and people
were like off it's a thing the man
who made alpha dog